hello I'm Greg Sadler and I would like
to invite you to our understanding anger
2.0 events these are sessions carried
out in YouTube live where I'll talk for
a bit about the literature that we're
looking at that particular month and I
answer questions address comments
there's a lot of great insights about
the emotion of anger that come to us
from philosophy literature
psychology history religious studies all
sorts of disciplines and I teach these
in my classes and I've done previous
lecture series about this so I decided
to start it back up again it's an
open-ended series it might go on for
years and years and I'd love for you to
join me as we look at what ancient
medieval even modern thinkers and
writers have to tell us about this
difficult emotion goes on for about 90
minutes generally first part of it I've
got some notes prepared I'll open up the
texts for you and show you what's going
on give you some of the insights that
they have to communicate and then we go
into a conversation where you can write
your comments and questions and I will
do my best to address them so hopefully
you can join me for some of these
understanding anger 2.0
events